map kinase signaling pathway so in this
video we are going to talk about map
kinase signaling pathway and map kinase
signaling pathways stands for
mitogen-activated protein kinase so map
k-means mitogen-activated protein kinase
so what is a mitogen mitogen is a growth
factor so mitogen is a substance that
would promote mitosis meet that mean it
will promote cell division and we can
see that in this signaling pathway a lot
of protein kinase is playing an
important role and which will ultimately
promote the expression of cyclin d1 so
let's go step by step
so mitogen binds to its receptor and
this receptor is often receptor tyrosine
kinase and this mitogen could be any
growth factor so this receptor could be
igf-1 or veg F so this mitogen can bind
to this receptor and upon mitogen
binding this receptor will undergo some
conformational change that its cytosolic
domain there is a tyrosine kinase enzyme
that will phosphorylate the receptor the
receptor still so here we can see in
this phosphotyrosine residues grb-2 can
dock grb-2 is growth factor receptor
binding protein 2 so it is an adaptor
molecule of this receptor tyrosine
kinase so adaptor can bind to receptor
and can further activate further
signaling components so [ __ ] grb-2 or
grab two will activate the SOS SOS
stands for one of seven lists in
drosophila so this protein was first
reported in drosophila and that is why
it is called the sole of 7s the mutant
phenotype was one of seven less so
however this SOS can
convert rats gdb to rest gtp which is a
activated form of the rest so Raz is a
monomeric g-protein and this is very
important in this signaling pathway
grass is very important component of
this signaling pathway because rats
activate ref it's another factor however
ref can activate make and then make an
activate arc arc and activate
sequentially force here we can see this
raf and the whole downstream signaling
pathway is activated sequentially so
here is a kinase cascade and that is why
it's called map kinase pathway so
mitogen is activating some protein
important protein kinases and each step
you can see the number of kindnesses are
getting increased so each step there is
a amplification of the signal whatever
signal is coming from this receptor site
it's amplified at every step here you
can see and so here is 3 make you can
see and in the next step more arcs are
generated and then even more force are
generated and this force will act as a
transcription factor and it will migrate
to the nucleus you can see force goes to
the nucleus and force is a a p1 family
of protein and it will bind to the a p1
region of the DNA and it will bring
about the transcription of some specific
genes most importantly cyclin d1 and
cellular make seaming and the cyclin d1
helps in cell survival I mean cyclin d1
helps in cell division and thus it will
lead to cell survival and the Simic has
also role in cell survival so this whole
map kinase pathway is a important
proliferation pathway cell proliferation
pathway so this particular path
is very important because in the cancer
cell what happens this pathway goes
wrong as it's a cell survival pathway
and it promotes cell proliferation so if
this pathway goes wrong and uncontrolled
then what happened the cells behave and
behave differently and their growth
pattern is totally uncontrolled so they
became immortal and then divide rapidly
what happens in that cancer cell so this
particular pathway is very important for
cell the normal cells and also when this
pathway goes wrong and pathway is super
active super active and this pathway
mainly do cancer what happens in the
cancer this pathway is not switched off
so upon the mitogen binding this pathway
gets switched on but what happens in the
cancer cell sometimes the amount of
nitrogen is high sometimes the receptor
are mutated so they don't actually need
the mitogen to bring about this
signaling pathway
sometimes the wrath is mutated and the
grass is always active that's a
constitutive active form of rest and
thus the whole downstream cascade is
activated in the cancer cell so this
pathway is very important in context of
cancer however in the normal case the
cyclin D expression is done by this
pathway so this pathway is also normal
also very important in normal cell thank
you please like and subscribe